hey what is up guys of Kim PhD here and
welcome to yet another video on the
oneplus one probably the phone that I've
done the most individual videos on on
this channel so if you've owned a one
plus one over the past couple of months
there's two things that you've been
waiting for for a while number one
CyanogenMod 12s extension an update from
CyanogenMod 11s book on top of lollipop
and number two oxygen OS the update and
the operating system built specifically
for the oneplus one by one plus
so oxygen OS is finally available for
download and i have to actually flash
the zip on my oneplus one it's available
to about a seven hundred and fifty
megabytes i'll also leave linked repet
like button if you want to install
yourself and i asked on twitter if you
guys want to see a video about it
despite also saying that it's a pretty
small update a pretty simple thing but a
lot of you guys were interested so here
is one plus ones oxygen OS 1.0 so the
first thing you'll notice about oxygen
OS is just how close it feels and looks
to stock android so if you use the nexus
5 or nexus 6 that's what a lot of this
is going to remind you of and actually
it's built on top of android 5.0.2 so
it's not the latest version of android
like an actual nexus would be built on
but you notice basically all the user
interface and google now and this
launcher and everything here is just
like stock android so what i think is
the biggest new feature of this OS at
least from what i've seen and used is
the quick settings so this is what the
normal quick settings for android 5.0
would look like and that's fine
but if you at this little quad box up
here you can actually rearrange where
things are and what shows up here so you
can tap what's add don't use airplane
mode very much where i don't use the
flashlight you can tap to toggle which
things show up and which things don't
you hit save and there's your new quick
settings so you can toggle and control
the stuff really easily let's say i want
all the stuff there I can touch it all
and toggle it all back and if I ever
want to reset it I can do that too so
that seems like the main feature being
able to easily quickly customize what
shows up in your quick settings box here
since that's something I guess Android
users use a lot there's also a couple of
other features from CyanogenMod 11s that
you may recognize so if I go into the
settings here you have buttons and
gestures buttons are just the buttons on
the bottom of the phone so you can turn
on or
off the on screen buttons let's say you
want the off screen capacitive buttons
you can use those too we're used to
being able to switch those on the
oneplus one and gestures are the screen
off gestures so let's say you want to be
able to draw a circle to quickly turn on
the camera while the phone screen is off
just draw that circle and it will open
you right up into the Google camera so
it's not the CyanogenMod camera or
anything special but that's what it'll
allow you to do so the gestures are
there and I actually found that a lot of
these we're activating in my pocket when
I was using CyanogenMod so I turn the
gestures off we can give them another
shot if you think double tap to wake or
drawing to open certain apps is worth
your time but everything else like you
can see here the launcher the Google now
home page being one swipe away from the
regular apps and screens and everything
like that all of this is still very
close to stock Android so almost nothing
else is modified here I did notice the
multitasking you get a nice little X
button up here in the top to clear all
your recent apps that's a little bit
different looking and it's new and it
looks kind of nice and like I said you
use a Google camera here and not any
sort of special camera app but it does
look like the pictures it takes are just
as good as you would get on previous
realms from anything like CyanogenMod
another thing to note is this comes with
all the Google apps installed already so
I did install the superuser app here to
get that root access but it is a 750
megabyte download and it doesn't come as
an OTA update so you have to download it
and flash it yourself by following those
instructions also I know people are
always interested in the wallpaper this
particular one I did add myself but this
does come with a couple of what's called
oneplus wallpapers it's just a couple of
them but they are pretty good-looking
and these are the ones that come with
oxygen OS if you want to try those out
so there you have it it's a very small
list of new things but that is oxygen OS
for the oneplus one it's a very simple
very clean very near stock rom it's not
the only simple clean near stock rom you
have Paranoid Android you have bliss pop
you have signage and mod you have a
bunch of other options but I feel like
they needed to get something out that's
stable and a little bit before signage
in mod 12 otherwise you'd have really no
reason to check this out that being said
I think this is a good place to start
because it's so simple and so clean and
at least so stable for right now this is
a good place to build on and they'll be
able to add future things add some new
features and options and customizations
further down the road with update
but this is 100 so at least it works and
hopefully it's more interesting with
future updates either way that's minute
thanks for watching and I'll talk to you
guys in the next one peace